*Clap*
Eh bien bonjour, vous allez regrettez d'avoir cliqué là-dessus.
Les amis, il y a un truc que je vous ai jamais dit c'est que je déteste certains bruits.
Alors comme tout le monde, Il y a plein de truc qu'on déteste genre la craie sur tableau etc...
Ces bruits là je les aime pas comme vous mais il y a des bruits que je déteste particulièrement !
Et c'est les bruits sourds et très forts.
Le truc qui atterrit d'un coup comme ça hyper fort ça me ....
Je ne sais pas j'ai envie de partir en courant et pleurer, mais vraiment hein.
C'est très bizarre, c'est pas juste ça qui me fait mal aux oreilles
C'est psychologiquement je ressens quelque chose de bizarre
Je ne sais pas ceux à quoi c'est lié.
Peut-être que quand ma mère était enceinte mon père me parlait avec un mégaphone.
En le collant au ventre de ma mère.
Et ça m'a traumatisé *rire* pire explication.
Bref je vous ai demandé sur Twitter de m'envoyer des vidéos de sons insupportables.
Pourquoi, parce qu'aujourd'hui, nouveau challenge ! Le "essayez de ne pas quitter la vidéo challenge" !
Vous m'avez donc envoyé des sons absolument ignobles.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi je nous inflige ça, pour être honnête, je n'en ai aucune idée.
Mais je sens que c'est important.
Ah bah attends, "Tiens Squeezie, j'espère que tu apprécieras ce magnifique moment".
"Top des bruits énervants" Bah parfait, c'est pile ce qu'il nous faut !
C'est parti ! Je sens que je vais regretter , mon gars, mais amèrement.
*Bruit / grincement de la craie*
*rire* Ça va, ça va, non franchement ça va.
En vrai, ça, ça va. Moi perso, je *bruit bizarre*
Alors la craie, ça fait un son de merde mais l'ongle c'est encore pire
parce que t'as la...juste en entendant l'ongle frotter, tu as la sensation qui va avec, tu sais sur ton ongle.
Et ça c'est horrible.
Ok, deuxième.
Boire à la paille au fond d'un verre
*rire*
Ok, je vous avoue un truc : ça je le fais tout le temps mec, j'suis le pire !
Ça, je le fais tout le temps. Mais attention, j'ai une bonne excuse, j'ai un toc en fait.
Quand je commande une boisson que j'ai payée, je vais la boire comme ça *mouvement étrange*
et en partant si il reste une goutte, j'vais pas être bien, j'vais me dire putain il reste deux centimes dans mon verre, c'est quoi ça
Et faut que je finisse les deux centimes et ce serait une grande preuve d'intelligence que de retirer la paille pour finir le verre, voilà, que je n'ai pas, bon
AAAAH!
ça c'est dur
ça c'est très dur
c'est pas le pire
*grimace* ah si quand même
*souffle*
*grognements*
ça j'ai envie de AH non mais ce bruit on est d'accord il est énervant pourquoi, parce que généralement quand tu l'entends, c'est le matin au petit-déjeuner.
Quand il y a ton frère ou ta sœur qu'est là et qui fait pas attention et qui fait son gros fils de PUTE.
Pardon excusez-moi, je me suis enflammé
Tu sais le matin quand vraiment quand tu mets ton pied en dehors du lit moi perso pendant une heure minimum faut que personne me parle.
Je suis hyper euuuh dans mon coin et si on me parle ça me fait chier.
Mais tais-toi Joséphine.
C'est généralement à ce moment-là que j'entends les gens manger.
Sinon le midi, j'm'en bats les couilles, j'vais me dire "putain il est très sale".
Mais le matin c'est : "putain je vais lui couper la tête".
Bref.
oh oui les trucs d'ASMR ça c'est affreuuux
J'en ai entendu une fois
Attendez, est-ce que c'est vraiment ça
*bruits de mastication*
*bruits de mastication bien fort*
Putain en plus je viens de manger ça me file la gerbe.